Toutes ces périodes sont restées
dans l’Histoire
pour avoir été le théâtre
de krachs boursiers:
des chutes importantes des valeurs
des actions
en seulement quelques jours
voire quelques heures.
Mais pourquoi ces krachs surviennent-ils?
Est-ce qu’il s’agit d’anomalies,
d’accidents de parcours,
ou juste du fonctionnement normal
de la bourse?
Aujourd’hui on va regarder cette question
non pas sous l’angle des mécanismes
économiques et financiers,
mais à partir d’analyses statistiques,
et on va faire le parallèle
avec d’autres phénomènes extrêmes
comme les tremblements de Terre.
[jingle]
La courbe que vous voyez ici, c’est
l’évolution du CAC40 sur 30 ans, depuis 1990.
Le CAC40 c’est un indice boursier,
c’est-à-dire une sorte de moyenne
des cours des 40 plus grosses entreprises
cotées à la Bourse de Paris.
Ce qui va nous intéresser aujourd’hui, ça
n’est pas son évolution globale,
mais ses variations quotidiennes,
c’est-à-dire qu’est-ce qu’il se passe
à l’échelle d’une journée,
est-ce que ça a monté, est-ce que ça a
baissé, et de combien?
Vous savez c’est ce chiffre que Jean-Pierre
Gaillard annonçait à la fin du journal,
"Je vous rappelle le CAC: +0.53%.
Pour France inter, J.P. Gaillard."
Dès fois c’est comme ça dans les 0.5%,
et puis dès fois c’est 1%, 2%, voire plus.
Pour faire des statistiques
sur ces variations,
j’ai téléchargé l’historique jour par jour
du CAC40 sur 30 ans,
on a quasiment 8000 valeurs.
J’ai calculé la variation quotidienne,
et j’ai fait un histogramme
avec des tranches de 0.1%,
voici ce que ça donne:
On voit que la très grande majorité du temps,
la variation est comprise entre -2% et +2%.
Alors 2% sur une journée, c’est déjà
énorme.
Quand on parle d’évolutions en économie:
de croissance, d’investissements,
ou d’inflation,
on parle en général de quelques % par an.
Là on parle de variations quotidiennes.
Et évidemment, quand on regarde de près,
on voit qu’on a régulièrement
des variations plus importantes: 3%, 4%,
et même un certain nombre de jours
avec des variations d’au moins 5%,
en positif ou en négatif.
Malgré tout, la forme générale de
l’histogramme est quand même assez familière.
Ça ressemble à une bonne courbe
en cloche.
C’est symétrique autour de 0,
il y a à peu près autant
de jours positifs que négatifs,
rien de très surprenant.
Vous savez peut-être que quand
on parle de courbe en cloche,
on fait référence à des courbes mathématiques
bien particulières
qu’on appelle les courbes de Gauss,
les gaussiennes,
qui sont notamment définies par leur largeur.
Là j’ai calculé la largeur de l’histogramme,
et j’ai tracé la gaussienne correspondante,
c’est une gaussienne dont l’écart-type est
de 0.72%,
et on voit que ça colle pas mal du tout.
Sauf que si on regarde de plus près,
ça colle bien au centre,
mais pas trop sur les bords.
On voit que l’histogramme est supérieur
à la gaussienne
dans les zones de 2-3% de fluctuations.
Et si on zoome sur les zones extrêmes,
au-delà de +2%, ou en-dessous de -2%,
on voit que ça ne colle pas franchement.
La gaussienne est quasiment nulle au
delà de 3%,
alors qu’il y a eu plein de journées
qui ont présenté
des variations de cet ordre,
en positif ou en négatif.
Ce qu’on constate en y regardant
de plus près,
c’est que les fluctuations du CAC40
collent assez bien
avec une gaussienne quand elles sont faibles,
mais pour les variations importantes,
ça ne marche pas du tout.
Une façon de s’en rendre compte, c’est de
se rappeler
que notre gaussienne qui colle bien,
son écart-type est de 0.72%,
or on a eu des journées avec des variations
à 7%, donc 10 fois l’écart-type.
Si les fluctuations suivaient vraiment
la courbe en cloche,
ce genre de choses ne devrait jamais arriver.
C’est lié aux mathématiques
de la loi gaussienne.
Par exemple ici une variation de 3%,
c’est 4 fois l’écart-type, on note ça 4 sigmas.
Or quand on a une gaussienne, une variation
de 4 fois l’écart-type
ne devrait se produire qu’une fois
sur 15 000 en moyenne.
Donc sur 8000 jours d’historique,
ça aurait dû arriver
une fois peut-être ou 2-3 fois grand maximum.
Et avec une gaussienne, 5 sigmas ça n’arrive
en théorie qu’une fois sur 2 millions environ.
Donc toutes ces variations qui sont là
ne devraient jamais se produire,
si c’était une vraie courbe en cloche.
Pour bien se représenter cette histoire,
faisons la comparaison
avec un truc dont on sait qu’il se comporte
bien comme une courbe en cloche: notre taille.
Prenons les hommes en France, leur taille
moyenne est d’environ 1m75
avec un écart-type d’environ 7.5cm.
J’ai simulé ce que ça donne
avec 8000 personnes,
voilà le graphique équivalent.
Ici 4 fois l’écart-type, ça fait par
exemple un homme de 2m05.
Bon parmi 8000 personnes c’est pas absurde
de se dire que vous aurez quelqu'un de 2m05.
Mais 10 fois l’écart-type, c’est 2m50!
C’est comme si c’était fréquent que parmi
8000 personnes prises au hasard
on trouve quelqu’un qui fait 2m50.
Conclusion: les tailles semblent être bien
gaussiennes,
mais pas les variations du CAC40.
Alors est-ce que c’est grave si
ce n’est pas gaussien?
Finalement pourquoi est-ce que ça le serait?
La raison pour laquelle les courbes en cloche
« gaussiennes » sont si fréquentes en science,
c’est qu’elles se comportent comme des
attracteurs.
Si quelque chose dépend de la contribution
d’un grand nombre de facteurs qui s’ajoutent,
on s’attend à avoir une gaussienne.
Derrière cette affirmation un peu floue,
il y a un théorème mathématique précis
et très important, le théorème
"central limite",
et qui le dit de façon plus formelle.
Mais l’important c’est que ce théorème
permet de comprendre
et justifier l’omniprésence des gaussiennes
dans tout un tas de situations.
Par exemple dans le cas de la taille,
on sait qu’elle dépend de probablement
plusieurs centaines de gènes,
en plus d’être influencée évidemment
par notre alimentation
et notre environnement en général.
Et donc ça n’est pas surprenant
que la résultante
de toutes ces contributions,
ce soit une gaussienne.
Mais pourquoi ça ne marche pas avec la
Bourse?
Pourtant on s’attendrait à ce que
ce soit pareil.
Les évolutions du CAC40 dépendent
des décisions
de dizaines de milliers d’acteurs qui
achètent, vendent plusieurs fois par jour.
Pourquoi le résultat ne sont pas
des fluctuations gaussiennes?
Notez que ce serait super bien
si c’était gaussien.
Ça nous garantirait en quelque sorte
que les variations ne puissent
pas être trop importantes,
et qu’une fluctuation de plus ou moins 4%
soit quasi impossible.
Sauf que non, ça ne marche pas.
Bon alors si c’est pas gaussien,
essayons de comprendre ce que c’est,
et regardons de plus près
ces événements extrêmes.
Pour faire cela, je vais utiliser une
représentation un peu différente.
Déjà je vais compter ensemble
les fluctuations positives et négatives.
On a vu que c’était assez symétrique,
donc je vais juste m’intéresser
au pourcentage de fluctuations,
indépendamment de si c’est
en plus ou en moins.
Voici ce que ça donne, et cette fois
l'histogramme c'est le % de probabilité
d’avoir une fluctuation supérieure
à la valeur.
Par exemple ici à 2% j’ai
une probabilité de 7%
parce que sur mes 8000 jours d’historiques,
il y en a eu 540
où ça a varié de plus de 2%, donc
environ 7% du total des jours
Et j’ai à nouveau représenté ce qu’on
attendrait
si les fluctuations étaient gaussiennes.
On voit que ça colle au début,
mais pas à la fin.
Cette extrémité c’est ce qu’on appelle la
"queue" de la distribution.
Et là on dit qu’on a à faire à
une distribution à queue épaisse,
"fat tail" en anglais.
Alors qu’est-ce qui collerait avec
cette queue épaisse?
Pas la gaussienne, puisqu’on voit
qu’elle décroît trop vite.
Il faut qu’on trouve quelque chose
qui décroît moins vite qu’une gaussienne.
Mathématiquement une gaussienne, c’est en gros
une fonction du genre exponentielle
de -x au carré, je vous l’ai tracée ici.
Et on connaît tout un tas de fonction
qui décroissent moins vite
que les gaussiennes,
ce sont les fonctions de la forme
1/x puissance alpha,
où alpha est un nombre réel plus grand que 1.
En voici quelques unes: 1/x,
1/x au carré,
1/x au cube, 1/x puissance 4,78
on peut faire ce qu’on veut.
On voit que plus alpha est grand,
plus la fonction décroît vite,
mais dans tous les cas, la gaussienne finit
toujours par décroître encore plus vite.
Ces fonctions on les appelle
des "lois de puissance",
puisque c'est 1/ x puissance alpha.
(1/x^alpha)
Est-ce qu'elles pourraient aller
avec notre histogramme,
pour remplacer la gaussienne.
Pour le savoir, on pourrait essayer
plein de valeurs de alpha
et voir ce qui colle, mais il y a
un moyen plus direct.
C’est un peu technique mais si je vous perds,
ne vous inquiétez pas,
ça n’est pas très important.
Imaginez que j’aie une loi: y = 1/x^alpha,
si je prends le logarithme des deux côtés,
j’ai: log (y) = -alpha * log (x) .
En logarithme, ma loi devient juste
une relation de proportionnalité.
Donc ce qu’on va faire, c’est qu’on va
tracer notre distribution
des fluctuations du CAC40, mais
en échelle logarithmique,
et on va voir si on obtient une droite,
signe de proportionnalité
et la pente, ce sera la valeur
de alpha qu’on cherche.
Alors allons-y avec les données du CAC40,
voici ce que j’obtiens,
c’est la courbe en bleu,
et en rouge la gaussienne.
La partie qui nous intéresse, c’est celle-ci,
celle des grandes fluctuations.
Pas les petites fluctuations dont on sait
qu’elles sont presque gaussiennes,
ni les très grandes, il y en a trop peu
pour qu’on puisse en tirer quoi que ce soit.
Dans la zone intermédiaire, la gaussienne
décroit beaucoup trop vite,
et on voit que les données du CAC40 forment
une partie presque linéaire,
dont on peut mesurer la pente,
et c’est quasiment -3.
Donc ça veut dire que la loi de puissance
à queue épaisse qu’on cherche,
ici c’est 1/x^3.
Les fluctuations ne sont pas gaussiennes
elles sont en 1/x^3.
Et ça explique que les fluctuations extrêmes
soient beaucoup plus fréquentes
que dans le cas d’une gaussienne.
Vous allez me dire: et alors?
Est-ce que ça c’est très profond
de savoir ça?
Déjà on l’a juste fait pour le CAC40.
Qu’est-ce qu’il se passe si on fait l’analyse
sur d’autres indices, ou bien sur des
actions.
Eh bien on va le faire!
En utilisant le langage Python,
il y a un petit module
pour télécharger directement des historiques
de cours depuis Yahoo Finance,
et j’ai donc fait le même genre
de représentation
que j’ai faite pour le CAC40,
mais cette fois
j’ai ajouté les données historiques
du DowJones à New York,
du Nikkei à Tokyo, du NASDAQ, et puis quelques
actions: Apple, Tesla, Ford et Toyota.
Et là c’est fou, les courbes se
superposent presque exactement,
et dans la zone qui nous intéresse, les grosses
fluctuations de plusieurs fois l’écart-type,
elles semblent toutes avoir
cette pente de -3.
Ca c’est quand même étonnant!
On prend des cours différents, d’industries
différentes,
dans des bourses de pays différents,
et on trouve
exactement la même chose,
c’est dingue, non?
Ce qu’on dit là c’est qu’il y a une forme
d’universalité
dans les fluctuations de la bourse.
Cette valeur de -3 elle n'est pas là
au hasard,
elle n’est pas spécifique du cac40.
La loi semble à peu près valable pour
tous les autres cours de bourse.
Et il doit y avoir une logique là-dedans,
une sorte de raison profonde,
un mécanisme sous-jacent
qui l’expliquerait.
On va essayer de comprendre quoi, mais
pour ça il va falloir nous intéresser
à la façon dont on traite d’autres types
de phénomènes extrêmes en physique.
Et on va commencer par de la géophysique,
avec l’étude des tremblements de terre.
[jingle]
Vous le savez sans doute, quand un tremblement
de Terre survient,
on mesure son intensité avec une échelle
qu’on appelle l’échelle de Richter.
C’est une échelle qui va de 0 à 9,
et qui est notamment reliée à la quantité
totale d’énergie libérée lors d’un séisme.
Vous avez ici une correspondance
approximative.
L’échelle 2, c’est une énergie d’environ
60 Mégajoules,
qui correspond à l’énergie libérée par
l’explosion de 15kg de TNT.
L’échelle 3 c’est 477 kg de TNT.
4 c’est 15 tonnes de TNT, etc.
A titre de comparaison, Hiroshima avait
une puissance équivalente de 15kTo,
donc magnitude 6 sur l’échelle de Richter.
Et la plus grosse bombe H jamais testée,
la Tsar Bomba,
57 Mégatonnes de TNT, elle est un peu
au-dessus de 8.
Une chose que vous remarquez
avec cette échelle,
c’est que ça n’est pas proportionnel,
la magnitude 8 n’est pas 2 fois
plus puissante que la magnitude 4.
Elle est 1 million de fois plus puissante!
En fait 2 points en plus sur l’échelle
de Richter,
c’est 1000 fois plus d’énergie libérée.
C’est une échelle logarithmique, pour ceux
qui connaissent,
ça marche un peu comme les décibels
pour le son.
Il y a une formule qui donne l’énergie en
fonction de la magnitude, je vous l’écris ici.
Intuitivement, on se doute bien
que les séismes plus puissants
sont heureusement plus rares,
mais plus rares de combien?
Pour le savoir, j’ai téléchargé
les données sismiques
de l’observatoire de Californie du Sud.
Vous savez peut-être que dans cette région,
à cause de la faille de San Andreas,
il y a une très forte activité sismique.
Les données que j’ai utilisées couvrent
la période de 1935 à nos jours,
et contiennent plus de 800 000
enregistrements.
La plupart de ces séismes sont très faibles,
on ne les ressent même pas et ce sont juste
les sismographes qui les détectent.
Mais dans mes données, on en trouve
quand même
plus de 2000 au-dessus de 4
sur l’échelle de Richter.
Intuitivement, on pourrait se dire
que, comme pour la taille des gens,
l’intensité des séismes suit
une distribution gaussienne.
Et pour vérifier ça, on va faire
le même jeu que tout à l’heure,
on va tracer les données en logarithmes.
Ici en abscisses vous avez l’énergie
du séisme en équivalent TNT,
et en ordonnées le nombre de séismes avec au
moins cette énergie,
en tout cas dans la base de données.
Et là ce qu’on voit, c’est à nouveau
une belle partie bien droite.
Là je l’ai fait avec l’énergie
que je trouve assez parlante,
mais si vous le faite avec la magnitude
ça marche aussi,
et avec ces unités on a une pente
très proche de -1,
on appelle ça la loi de Gutenberg-Richter.
Là pour le coup, c’est pas du tout gaussien.
La taille des séismes c’est pas comme la
taille des gens.
Et donc même question que pour la Bourse:
Pourquoi les tremblements de terre
ne suivent pas
la bonne courbe en cloche de la distribution
gaussienne?
En fait ce phénomène n’a rien
d’unique.
On retrouve un peu la même chose avec
les feux de forêt,
les avalanches, les éruptions solaires,
les épidémies,
tous ces phénomènes qui présentent souvent
des cas extrêmes.
En 1987, trois physiciens Bak, Tang et
Wiesenfeld on proposé
un modèle très simple pour expliquer
ces phénomènes,
ainsi qu’un concept nouveau qui aura
extrêmement influencé
la physique statistique des dernières
décennies: la criticalité auto-organisée.
Pour comprendre ça, imaginez un tas de sable
que l’on forme en versant assez doucement
des grains à son sommet.
De temps en temps, vous allez voir
des avalanches de grains de sable.
Ces avalanches peuvent être plus ou
moins grosses,
parfois c’est juste une toute petite zone,
et parfois vous avez une sorte
de réaction en chaîne.
Ce qui est intéressant, c’est que quand une
avalanche se produit,
le tas ne revient pas à un état où il serait
tout plat, et donc bien stable.
Non, l’avalanche s’arrête en laissant
le tas dans un état quasi-instable,
de sorte qu’une nouvelle avalanche
va pouvoir facilement apparaître.
C’est comme si le tas de sable, dans sa
façon d’évoluer, était naturellement
comme "attiré" par les états critiques,
instables, où les avalanches se produisent,
et ne s’en éloignait jamais vraiment.
Le tas se maintient toujours dans un état
proche de l’état critique.
Les états critiques sont comme
des attracteurs,
un peu comme dans certaines situations,
on a vu que les distributions gaussiennes
étaient des attracteurs.
Pour comprendre cet argument
de façon plus quantitative,
nos trois physiciens ont imaginé
un modèle très simple
qu’ils ont appelé le modèle du tas de sable,
même si vous allez voir qu’il correspond
à un tas de sable assez stylisé.
Imaginez une grille, et supposez
qu’à chaque seconde
je dépose un grain de sable au hasard
dans une des cases de la grille.
Ma grille va se remplir peu à peu,
et maintenant imaginez la règle suivante:
chaque fois qu’il y a plus de 4 grains
dans la même case,
on retire ces 4 grains et on les redistribue
sur les cases adjacentes.
C’est une sorte de mini avalanche.
Évidemment, ce faisant, certaines des cases
adjacentes
vont aussi éventuellement dépasser
le seuil critique,
et on va devoir redistribuer encore
aux voisins,
et ainsi de suite jusqu’à ce que ça s’arrête.
Et donc pour chaque grain qu’on ajoute
au hasard sur la grille,
on peut avoir des réactions en
chaîne plus ou moins longues.
Quand une avalanche de ce genre se produit,
on va quantifier son énergie
en comptant le nombre de réactions
dans la chaîne.
Si on redistribue juste une fois aux voisins
et c’est tout,
on dit que l’avalanche avait
une énergie de 1,
et si ça provoque une réaction avec 10 étapes
on dit qu’on a une avalanche
dont l’énergie est 10.
Et maintenant on va faire cette
simulation pendant un long moment,
et on va faire des statistiques sur
la taille des avalanches obtenues.
Vous me connaissez: j’ai programmé
la simulation,
ça a tourné un moment,
sur 100 000 pas de temps,
et voici ce que j’ai obtenu.
Vous voyez ici le film,
plus la case est claire,
plus il y a grains,
et quand elle devient blanche
on déclenche une avalanche.
Vous voyez que parfois certaines avalanches
sont petites,
et puis certaines sont vraiment longues,
ça fait une grande réaction en chaîne.
J’ai eu certaines avalanches qui ont fait
intervenir 7000 étapes, donc d’énergie 7000.
On peut faire comme pour
les tremblements de terre,
et tracer l’histogramme en échelle
logarithmique pour voir ce qu’on obtient.
Voici la courbe, et là bingo!
on a aussi une belle droite,
qui indique une distribution
en loi de puissance.
Et on peut chercher la pente,
c’est environ -1.
Avec ce modèle très simple,
on voit comment
un système peut naturellement
s’auto-organiser
autour d’états critiques, et présenter
des phénomènes
dont les énergies n’obéissent pas à
des distributions gaussiennes,
mais à une loi de puissance.
On parle de criticalité auto-organisée.
Alors le modèle vous paraît peut-être trop
simpliste,
mais c’est justement ce qui fait sa force
et qui explique l’universalité
des phénomènes.
Oubliez les grains de sable, et dites-vous
que chaque case représente un morceau
de la croute terrestre,
et qu’aléatoirement chacun de ces morceaux
est soumis à une contrainte supplémentaire
du fait des déplacements
des plaques tectoniques.
Les contraintes s’accumulent jusqu’à ce
qu’elles passent un seuil critique
et qu’elles soient relâchées
sur les cases voisines.
Parfois on va avoir des réactions en chaîne,
et vous avez là une version stylisée
d’un modèle de tremblement de terre.
Maintenant imaginez qu’il s’agit d’une
forêt qui brule,
ou bien tout simplement de la neige
qui tombe sur une zone de montagne.
Dès qu’on a une situation où quelque chose
s’accumule
et est susceptible de se décharger
sur ses voisins,
on peut se retrouver avec cette situation
de criticalité auto-organisée.
Ce modèle est assez convaincant et semble
bien fonctionner pour des phénomènes naturels.
Mais pour l’universalité des fluctuations
des cours de bourse,
ça ne semble pas vraiment coller, non.
Et en effet l’explication est
un peu différente,
elle a été proposée en 2009
par Xavier Gabaix,
un économiste français qui travaille
aux États-Unis.
Et pour comprendre l’idée, on va devoir
d’abord faire un détour
par un autre phénomène qui n’est pas du tout
gaussien: La taille des villes.
[jingle]
J’ai été sur le site de l’INSEE
pour télécharger des données
sur la population des communes de France,
et je les ai classées par taille.
J’ai un peu plus de 36000 communes,
les données ne sont pas parfaites,
pas totalement à jour, elles doivent
avoir quelques années.
Et on voit que ça va de la ville de Paris,
avec plus de 2 millions d’habitants,
à la mythique ville de Rochefourchat,
c'est dans la Drôme, avec… SON habitant.
Ah ouais, faut dire, c’est pas très grand!
Alors comment est distribuée
la taille des villes?
Est-ce que c’est gaussien comme la taille
des gens?
Avec beaucoup de villes moyennes,
peu de grandes villes
et peu de villes très petites?
Eh bien on va regarder!
Pour chaque ville, on va considérer
son rang dans le classement, de 1 à 36671,
et sa taille en nombre d’habitants,
et on va représenter chaque ville
par un point.
En abscisse le rang, et en ordonnées
la taille,
mais attention, vous commencez à être
habitués,
on va faire ça en échelle logarithmique.
Voici ce que ça donne, au rang 1 avec
plus de 2 millions d’habitants, on a Paris.
Puis Marseille, Lyon, Toulouse, etc.
Et tout en bas, ici, on a Rochefourchat.
Et on voit qu’on a à nouveau une sorte
de droite,
du moins pour les villes qui ont au moins
une centaine d’habitants.
Et la pente c’est presque exactement -1.
Cette distribution en loi de puissance
avec une pente de -1,
elle nous dit en gros que la 10 000ème ville,
va avoir 10 fois moins d’habitant
que la 1000ème ville, et 100 fois moins que
la 100ème ville.
Alors vérifions!
En 10000e position on a Saint-Jean-de-la-Motte,
et ses 844 habitants.
En position 1000 on a Pont-Audemer
et ses 8979 habitants, presque un facteur 10.
En position 100 c’est Maison-Alfort,
bon, seulement 51000 habitants,
mais l’ordre de grandeur est
quand même pas mal.
On voit que la pente colle un peu
moins pour les plus grandes villes,
mais si on prenait les agglomérations
urbaines je suis sûr qu’on serait pas loin.
Ce résultat est connu sous le nom
de loi de Zipf.
A l’origine ça avait été observé d’abord
sur la fréquence d’utilisation
des mots d’une langue.
Et dans le cas des villes, comme
pour la bourse
ça marche avec tout un tas de pays,
c’est pas spécifique de la France.
Mystère: pourquoi est-ce que toutes
les villes du monde
se retrouvent organisées comme ça les unes
par rapport aux autres?
Est-ce que comme pour les avalanches
on peut faire un petit modèle explicatif
qui reproduise le phénomène?
Eh bien oui on peut!
Et ce modèle a été justement proposé
par Xavier Gabaix.
L’idée est assez simple, il suffit
de supposer
que chaque ville a un taux de croissance
aléatoire,
mais que la distribution de probabilité
du taux, en pourcentage,
est la même pour toutes les villes,
grandes ou petites.
A nouveau, on va faire la simulation.
Imaginons un pays fictif avec 10
millions d’habitants
répartis équitablement dans 50 000 villes.
Donc il y a 200 habitants à chaque endroit.
C’est un peu extrême mais c’est
pour montrer l’idée.
Et supposons que chaque jour, la population
de chaque ville subisse une petite variation
dans un sens ou dans un autre,
le % de variation est tiré au hasard
pour chacune des villes indépendamment,
mais avec la même loi de probabilité.
J’ai pris une gaussienne d’écart-type 1%.
C’est un peu beaucoup mais c’est
pour que ça converge plus vite.
Et pour que la population augmente
globalement,
la gaussienne n’est pas centrée sur 0,
il y a un petit décalage.
Et j’ai simulé comme ça l’évolution de la
population de chaque ville sur 200 ans.
Avec le taux de croissance moyen
que j’ai choisi,
la population a été multipliée par 6
en 200 ans,
on arrive à une population d’environ
65 millions, comme la France.
Et regardez la distribution de
la taille des villes que j’obtiens.
Je suis parti de 200 personnes dans
chaque ville et maintenant
ma plus grosse ville a 1.9 millions
d’habitants, pas très loin de Paris.
Et dans l’ensemble c’est assez proche de la
vraie, et quasi-conforme à la loi de Zipf.
Ça, presque sans rien faire, juste avec
un modèle de croissance aléatoire,
en partant d’une répartition
totalement uniforme,
la population des villes a naturellement
convergé vers une distribution de Zipf.
On a donc un autre d’exemple d’universalité
qui s’explique par un phénomène d’attracteur
que l’on met en évidence avec
un modèle très simple.
Et notez qu’avec ce genre de modèle,
on peut expliquer de façon générale
un certain nombre de situations du genre
"plus on est riche, plus on s’enrichit".
On peut le prendre au sens littéral
de la richesse,
mais ça marche aussi par exemple pour
le succès des œuvres artistiques
comme les morceaux sur les plateformes
de streaming,
ou bien simplement la taille des entreprises,
qui suit, elle aussi, une loi de Zipf.
Et justement, grâce à ce point, revenons
à notre affaire de fluctuations boursières.
Je vous rappelle qu’on avait pour tâche
d’expliquer la fameuse loi de puissance en -3.
Un truc qu’il faut savoir, c’est que
ça n’est pas le seul phénomène mystérieux.
Si au lieu d’analyser les fluctuations
on analyse les volumes échangés chaque jour,
on tombe cette fois sur une pente
universelle de 1,5.
Et le modèle proposé par Xavier Gabaix
explique les deux à la fois:
la pente 1,5 des volumes,
et la pente 3 des fluctuations.
Pour cela, il suppose que les fluctuations
importantes
vont être à l’origine provoquées par des gros
porteurs.
Des gens, ou plutôt des institutions
qui pèsent lourd sur le marché,
on peut penser à des fonds de pension
par exemple.
C’est pas absurde comme idée,
regardez ici:
je vous ai mis les actionnaires majoritaires
de quelques grosses boites,
on retrouve tout le temps les mêmes noms,
les mêmes 6 ou 7 fonds de pension
sont toujours les actionnaires principaux
de ces entreprises.
Et Xavier Gabaix fait l’hypothèse que
pour un actif donné,
disons les actions d’une entreprise,
les porteurs sont distribués selon
la loi de Zipf.
Là non plus, ça n’est pas absurde,
en supposant que chaque acteur se comporte
de façon rationnelle,
et en calculant l’impact que cela peut avoir
sur les volumes échangés
et les fluctuations de cours, il montre alors
que l’on retombe exactement sur la pente -3
pour les fluctuations,
et la pente -1,5 pour les volumes.
L’intérêt de ce petit modèle est double:
d’une part il explique cette universalité
qu’on observe dans les données boursières,
et le fait que tout semble se passer
de la même façon
pour une entreprise industrielle à Tokyo
que pour une entreprise hi-tech à New York.
Et surtout, il permet de réaliser que les
fluctuations extrêmes que l’on observe
ne sont pas des anomalies extérieures
au système,
mais juste la continuité normale
d’une loi statistique,
une loi de distribution à queue épaisse,
comme c’est le cas pour
les tremblements de terre.
Voilà c’est tout pour aujourd’hui,
je suis conscient
que ça fait beaucoup de maths d'un coup,
mais j’espère
que cette petite balade à travers
le monde merveilleux des lois de puissance
vous aura fait découvrir
des choses nouvelles.
Comme toujours plus d’info sur le blog,
en particulier si vous voulez
en savoir plus sur la façon dont j’ai fait
les statistiques et codé les simulations.
Comme toujours abonnez-vous,
partagez si ça vous à plu.
Et on se retrouve très vite pour
des nouvelles vidéos. À bientôt!
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -